well tonight wraps up our first week  here at the Largo theater wonderful  comedy theater in Los Angeles and we're  so happy that we could take over this  space I'm doing this in the safest way  possible we have just very few crew  members working around me everyone's  wearing masks  everyone is socially distance and  everyone has been tested yeah as an  added precaution it was my idea that  that all crew members be sterilized I  was told this was not necessary but I  really don't want them having kids  anyway moving on the entire audience as  you can imagine is empty except for my  trusty assistant Sona always by my side  hey Sona how's it going why you so much  further back than you were the other  time you're practically out in the lobby  why are you back that way why would you  leave when I'm shooting a show this is  exciting you don't get ramen while I'm  shooting a show how do you think the  show is going so far nice to have an  audience thanks Donna